the sounds of War ring out in a
residential neighborhood in Haiti's
Capital residents joined plain clothes
police trying to fight off an attack
from a gang hoping to extend its
territory to selino since Sunday armed
men have repeatedly attacked it amid a
fresh offensive on Thursday the worst so
far residents fled their homes or were
forced
out I'm on the street because of armed
gangs they took my house I was
Sheltering in another neighborhood but
they invaded it too I'm on the street
now I don't know where to
go other residents erected makeshift
barricades in a bid to protect
themselves and called local radio
stations for help most of Porto p is
under control of criminal gangs and if
solino falls they could start to Target
other areas of the city that until now
were thought to be
safe in the power struggle between
between organized crime and the police
civilians are often caught in the
crossfire murders in the first 9 months
of 20203 were up by over 70% as compared
to the same period the year
before on Sunday I was sitting with a
friend near my house when three bullets
came in one broke my bone but I can't
afford to go to the
hospital amid the growing violence
there's also growing resentment
residents protested against president
Ariel Omri decrying his failure to
tackle the country's growing
lawlessness we are asking the entire
metropolitan area to stand up the entire
Republic must rise to make Ariel enri
respond we can no longer resist
insecurity by gangs nothing is
functional not even the Democratic
institutions we want elections free of
gangs the head of state is not even
involved in gangs the whole country is
gangsterz
in October the UN Security Council voted
to send Kenyan troops to stop the
violence but their deployment was
blocked by a Kenyan High Court until at
least the end of this month camil nedel
Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer